you as President Joe Biden's hand might
be strengthened back at home with the
latest U.S Senate win while at the
association of Southeast Asian nation's
annual Summit in cambodia's Phnom Penh
he forged an important strategic
partnership
as the meeting Drew to a close Biden
promised to deepen tithes with the 10
country block the initiatives comes as
the U.S seeks to boost its influence in
the region in the face of an
increasingly assertive China Biden is
due to meet with China's president Xi
Jinping at the G20 Summit in Bali on
Monday foreign
we can now speak to DW correspondent
Georg mattes who is in Phnom Penh hello
to UK org so asean as we just mentioned
has signed up to this strategic
partnership with the U.S what exactly is
that going to mean
it basically means that relations have
been lifted to a new level so we will
see closer economic cooperation but also
closer strategic cooperation there was a
good example here for closer Maritime
cooperation because the U.S president
suggested using a private satellite
networks for instance to track down
illegal fishing so to track ships in the
South China see more effectively a lot
of illegal fishing going on for instance
by China is what Southeast Asian states
are concerned about but one has to say
it is largely symbolic it is an upgrade
in relations that China already got last
year so it will really depend on what
the U.S and asean will make of this
so some advantages for the Southeast
Asian Nations but what about President
Biden's benefits of this is he leaving
The Summit in a stronger position than
ahead of his meeting with Xi Jinping on
Monday in Bali at the G20
I'd say most certainly it was a good
opportunity to meet with allies not just
from Southeast Asia but also from East
Asia because today is the asean East
Asia Summit it's also been an
opportunity to gain new allies and to to
talk with them about various subjects
everything from South China Sea to
Myanmar one has to say however the real
problem that Biden faces in this region
is that Southeast Asian states don't
want to pick sites and there was a good
picture of that illustrating it yet
yesterday's Gala dinner the U.S
president and the Chinese Premier were
Seated on either side of the host hunsen
the leader of Cambodia
well meanwhile the U.S Japan and South
Korea talked about North Korea how much
of a role has the recent escalation of
tensions uh played at the summit
it is of course a concern for regional
stability in a region that was
particularly hard hit by covet
economically for many countries that is
a is a big concern so the last thing
they would like to see is an escalating
conflict in North Korea and the latest
missile tests in North Korea are very
much a concern at today's sidelines of
the East Asia asean's Summit North South
Korea rather Japan and the US will meet
and have bilateral or trilateral talks
and a key issue will be North Korea
because the hope is that the American
president will use his meeting with
Chichen ping the Chinese leader at the
G20 meeting in Bali to put pressure on
the key Ally of North Korea that is
China to cool down a bit
DW's Garg mantis in plump and Georg
thank you so much